[Music]
growing up with the ladies where you
would you say you call yourself a late
bloomer an early bloomer where were you
on the spectrum I think it was a pretty
early bloomer Maya my first kiss was
actually a threesome thank you thank you
I know actually I I I guess okay fourth
grade right Molly
great fourth grade widget you're flush
kiss was in fourth my first kiss was in
fourth grade Molly cabinets Nicky
accuracy how you guys doing I was riding
my bike they were walking I was well I
know I was riding him home like a
gentleman yeah we get to Nikki's house
and there's there's a big Bush up front
of her house and so I go I go behind the
bush with Nicky and we and she gives me
a peck on the cheek
Nicky leaves the bush Molly comes in
gives me a peck on the cheek yeah Molly
leaves Nicky comes back in knit and then
Nick just like a french fry I know it's
crazy because I'm running in and out of
we were like experimenting and what
ended up happening was you know the
other person would time for a minute and
we have to kiss for like a minute I mean
the other person won't come in so I
guess it wasn't a threesome because I'm
at the boat I'm know that was an
incredible first kiss I mean that that's
what amazingly something a very erotic
experience you're behind a bush and
people are coming and going and it
sounds like there's role-playing and
that was
I think it ended up the last thing we
did was I was laying down and they were
laying on top of me by kissing though
just kissing for one minute were you how
old how will this force great that's
amazing yeah that's incredible yeah Wow
it was great I mean I haven't seen them
in a very long time I don't even know
them anymore but uh well I have to go in
I think you're gonna hear from them you
just completely outed them I know
they're home with their families right
now married and okay now did your
parents were they they find out that
you're this they suddenly they have this
son who's taking wait he's behind the
bushes and Mike they did find that out
and my dad actually has an interesting
profession he's a he's a nurse midwife
and I think there's like there's 50 male
midwives in the country so he delivers
babies for a living Wow
and I actually went in my senior year of
high school I got to go in with him to
work and actually be there to to see
what he does
you saw babies born when you were a
senior in in high school and after birth
and blood and yeah a lot was it was
great it was great because I would think
that would be that would teach you to
yeah before yeah well I mean my dad
would come home my birds-and-the-bees
talk was ridiculous birds-and-the-bees
talk
before there's no birds in the Beast
talk before we got to that point though
he would bring home pictures of just
these books of every single sexually
transmitted disease so I was very very
scared of sex he had he brought books so
he's are like coffee table book I just
can't come oh I just delivered a 13 year
old girls baby you know I was very very
scared Wow okay so okay so he he got me
in shape real fast yeah he scared you
straight he sure did
sounds like he did terrible damage yeah
he actually did it now that's what I was
thinking but I didn't say that's why I'm
here buddy yeah I'm like sounds good and
it's about spur if ik I'm on the wrong
couch yeah